her so no matter how bad his position is
he'll find resources he'll always look
for the positives um as we saw yesterday
against the niche bouncing back from
adversity and here we go the games have
started white pushes the queen's pawn
aronian's favorite move traditionally
which opening will we see nimzo india
defense yeah it's a nimzo black's bishop
coming out pinning one of the white
knights
and okay the classical variation
and a very strategic approach from
aronian this one's gone out of fashion a
bit lately from the white side black is
supposed to have a few antidotes to this
setup
um here black can bring
one of the knights out black can just
castle the king
i can capture a pawn in the center lots
of options white just wants to
fiancato's bishop and then get the king
castled as quickly as possible it's
always kind of
i always think of it like a hybrid this
opening a nimso indian and a catalan
mixed up all in one simon ivanka what do
you think of this opening choice by
iranian
yeah
i guess he's going for a more uh
positional approach which i think is
correct against duda dude is very sharp
loves attacking and
i think there was a lot of battles
casper of karpov went
maybe the 88 world championships or yeah
in this opening and um it's i mean it's
it
this is all fury so far and we see that
black now you know capturing they're
going to double the pawns but white does
have this lovely light square bishop and
black's got this horrible light square
bishop so this is one of the positional
reasons that white plays this this line
on the other on the other side white's
going to have double pawns so it but
there's been what tens of thousands of
games in this or thousands at least
yeah uh there's been very very popular
and uh now white has reached a
crossroads this is why levon aronian has
taken a pause you can actually capture
that bishop with the pawns double your
pawns as simon suggests but it's also
possible to capture that piece with a
bishop but okay levon still treading the
main line and
now play is just developing very
naturally both sides getting their kings
to safety
and okay
this one
is slightly unusual i mean it could just
simply change into something more
popular but it's it was actually a lot
more popular in this position to attack
the pawn with the knight go to the edge
of the board
yeah as far as i know this has
definitely fallen out of uh fashion
what dude is doing at least capturing
this uh night a couple of moves ago
doubling the white pawns looks very
logical but nowadays players from the
black side they've been choosing
slightly different ideas and i guess we
have to jump in and discuss because this
is already uh long term it's going to be
complex now it's all about these balls
ivanka you mentioned already on the last
move black could go and start attacking
the front of the doubled pawns this
one's really hard to defend often in the
nimzo indian defense
and
already white might be asked to
sacrifice this pawn in order to get some
dynamic compensation
instead in the game he's pushed the ball
forward
these guys are still weaknesses the
black bishop maybe wants to come out and
attack this pawn at some point and levon
aronian i was about to ask what should
he be playing here he needs to be
energetic right to compensate
for this uh
structural weakness so he jumps in with
his knight
very concrete
very kind of direct from aronian
looking at this night now with his
bishop that's why the knight swapped
itself off for a bishop and okay a trait
of knights on this square
and i guess aronia's idea is to play
this position at least now both sides
have these uh kind of
weird doubled pawns
who's this gonna favor it's not clear to
me to be honest
the question is can white kind of
correct his pawn structure if he can
force black to take in uh in this manner
then suddenly white has the advantage
because he has a nice pawn center but if
black doesn't capture in the current
position
maybe he can put pressure on this pawn
maybe he just defends uh moves his queen
out for example keeps the tension
very complex all the knights off the
board
well i bet they don't want uh rooks and
queens in that line then
because that's not going to be very open
any time soon i guess no
i guess white wants to just bring the
rooks across
yeah it's uh it's unclear at the moment
i'm really surprised that both sides
have played so quickly up to this point
because
black was taking some big strategic
risks and then levon aronians just said
okay i'm not going to try and punish you
i'm just going to swap off all the
pieces
what do you think of that decision
i'm yeah i mean has it ever been played
no it's not being played before but i
think it's a part of the player's
strategy to just maximize the tension
you know there's a lot of
pressure in the center you know there's
a lot of possibilities there and now
my mind has gone blank a little bit um
i'm only a studer this is uh i i just
got a bit uh put off by richard
rapport's face
[Laughter]
underneath underneath there's a picture
of where you and richard report so i i i
lost the momentum because i was thinking
richard but it's not richard it's duda
uh step forward with the queen and uh
there we see the players getting ready
and uh you know earlier on we talked
about
the semi-finals it's all going to be
about mental strength it's also going to
be about drama and what they're going to
bring to the chess board
and you know the heat is on the party's
getting started and this is like the
perfect time to launch our selfie
competition
because we want to know how you at home
are watching the tour
and there is a prize up for grabs so one
lucky winner will win one year's chess
24 premium membership for free and of
course as always you can tweet us your
selfies remember in landscape mode using
the hashtag chesschamps and we will
feature them on the show absolutely love
seeing your selfies
yeah we love seeing selfies and
personally i love seeing queen exchanges
it means we'll go down to an end game
and the players will grind it out but
what do we think of this offer of a
queen trade does black say yes or does
black run away
if you capture the white queen you
double another set of pawns
yeah i mean i i think these in these
positions it all depends whether black
can play bishop to a6 at some point i
think he has to exchange queens and he
has to play this move without this move
black's just going to be very defensive
in a bad position and we're going to get
actually lots of simplifications here
over the next couple of moves and i
think it's going to be clear uh to see
very soon if i'm i'm sure it's white
who's pushing for an advantage if white
will
be able to get an advantage um out of
the opening and uh um okay black's
playing a very natural move there
bringing the rook to d8 he played that
very quickly again david you're
mentioning how quickly they're moving
it's one of those positions where come
on maybe just slow down because if you
if you play it a bit quickly here it's
going to be a very simple position where
you could just be worse
and there are other options there um you
know you could attack the bishop there
surely that that looked much more
natural to me um so i i'm wondering you
know that that that last move it might
be okay but what happens here i mean
white's got two pawns on pre it still
actually seems okay for black doesn't it
at the moment i think
so what is temporarily a pawn up so
levon will be looking for ways to
consolidate that i'm not really sure how
to be honest um like you say there are
two pawns attacked in the current
position if we jump in um just to show
what's happening here white did win a
pawn on this square
but as you mentioned bishop takes pawn
big threat and pawn takes pawn followed
by a rook recapture
lots of pressure on this pawn in the
center
and the only way i can see to defend
both is to there we go
the irish pawns
tripled pawns but at least temporarily
white is two pawns up and black can only
gain one back at a time so
you can capture this pawn which actually
looks very tempting because the black
bishop gets into the position
attacking this guy
the other option would be to play pawn
takes pawn on this square but white
could just retreat the bishop and
suddenly no captures uh because this
would lead to a really bad rook and pawn
end game for black just to pawn down and
white has an outside pass pawn
potentially
so uh i guess this is possible but then
he would just flick his bishop back
instead wow he goes for an approach i
hadn't considered to be honest uh in
this position he just says okay i'll
beat two pawns down i don't mind just
gonna step back where he came from
that's really interesting simon you
mentioned coming to this square one move
ago
he plays it now
i guess all the targets lie here
i think it does allow this move
i think just a couple more moves david
and we will be able to give a very good
verdict like okay probably here white's
going to play a4
and
we can slow down now and like
if anyone's got advances it must be
white because he's got that extra pawn
which gives him an extra tempo to do
something with
um like trying to get his rook into the
game um
but of course there's a lot of pieces
being exchanged here so a draw must be
something that comes to mind as well
right yeah
rook end game it will be level uh level
number of pawns dude didn't actually
take this pawn yet he just doubled up
first he will take this pawn next yeah
as you say simon it should be a draw
with best play remind me why we picked
this game
but is it so easy i mean
i mean for instance why it does have
that time as a simon highlighted just to
cause a little bit of a nuisance you
know you kind of highlighted with your
iris root coming to
the d line and perhaps to the seventh
row and
then you know maybe he will try to
involve the a rook into the game yeah
for example rook takes pawn the white
rook comes up say black's rook tries to
fight for the seventh rank and now you
advocate just bringing the other
opponents yeah
yeah potentially i guess it's hard to
imagine black uh being in too much
trouble if the king for example just
steps across
the king will try and come across and
evict the white rook from this strong
square
has
doesn't seem like anything to me really
yeah i mean
black doesn't really have any weaknesses
does he except for the activity of
white's pieces and it's going to be very
hard to win this when when you don't
have weakness as black um this is kind
of the only idea which white can try i
think to to get a brook active okay he's
gone
he's gone with this move here
interesting okay so this is actually
maybe a clever way of doing it right
david so yeah defending this pawn if
it's captured then we would see a rook
trade and now white does gain a bit of
time because suddenly there's a
thread of checkmate on the board black's
king is actually trapped and if you take
a time out to deal with that say the
black king moves towards the center or
get some breathing space then white does
get the rook to the seventh rank this is
the key you need the rook um now to hit
this pawn so
if you win this pawn some trance has
some very good chances for iranian very
clever move there from aronian i think
because uh
he he now obviously has the opportunity
if he gets one more move to defend that
extra pawn you know a minimum or to
bring the rook to the open file so uh
yeah there's actually you know just i
missed this move but this this is going
to ask some questions to do that uh
whether he can uh keep the balance here
uh i mean ronin's everyone's great
endings at this level but aronian just
has so much experience doesn't he he's
i've seen him win
so many rook endings against 27 2800s
even in the past and uh well maybe not
twenty eight hundreds there's not many
of them about but twenty seven hundred
let's say i remember playing magnus in
some rook and games yeah and playing
yeah and he he's
very very yeah he's up there with magnus
is one of the best in-game players
around so so maybe there's something
here maybe maybe maybe a little little
nibble as we say what is the most common
end game
yeah because they start in the corner
don't they and they're really they're
like slugs really you know they they
come into life later on but they're just
like they just creep around in the
corner for most of the game you know
just they're doing nothing and then
off they go like like now and uh they're
very very powerful in the ending um so
yeah
i do say all right games are drawn but
uh yeah hopefully not this one
quite like that uh tweets there from
grand master blunders who says i'm
working
and keep those selfies coming in
remember there is a prize up for grabs
one year chess 24 premium membership
absolutely
right
well dude is uh definitely thinking two
minutes uh on this move so is he now
looking at should i take this into
something uh jewish i think a rook end
game is going to be a draw or do you
think he can find something
yeah it's difficult as simon mentioned
there is this kind of
flaw in the plan if you go and regain
your pawn right now
if black does capture this black pawn as
this white pawn as we just showed so
if you don't take that pawn if you just
sit maybe for example bring the black
king towards the center you're basically
saying i'm going to be a pawn down for
the next 20 30 moves and yes it should
still be a draw because black's rooks
are active attacking pawns
the white rooks will be passive
defending pawns so probably it's just a
draw but
from a kind of kind of psychological
point of view do you want to sit there
upon down knowing that you are the one
fighting for the draw you are never
going to win the game
so it's just duda i think having that
um kind of chat with himself that
philosophical chat and he decides okay i
can't grab the pawn back so irony is
going to be a pawn up for a long time
now but the black rooks do control a
whole bunch of squares
white has a lot of weaknesses to be
honest as well
even if okay the rook comes across even
if the white king tries to centralize
later white has an isolated h pawn
yeah it's going to be difficult to win
this one for iranian but he is the only
one who can win it but i i think uh love
is being very sneaky with his rook moves
you know he's over protecting the pawn
standing on b5 and uh he quickly plays
the move that's why i was thinking
and now i mean isn't this a little bit
uncomfortable
maybe
and dude it says no
no no no no no dude doesn't seem scary
he's not look at him you know the light
is shining on his face it's always a
good sign
and the light shines on the righteous
and on duda
[Laughter]
and the problem for white is okay after
this porn trade
everything's just disappearing and black
is going to take one of the white pawns
now
there we go
white goes to pawn up again but after a
rook exchange we will see
a structure where
okay he doesn't trade a set of rooks
really interesting i was going to say he
could take one of the white rooks go
behind white's extra sea pawn with his
remaining rook and that should be a draw
that type of position but
he keeps both sets of rooks on the board
this kind of looks dead draw to me i
mean i think he's going to win a pawn
back isn't he now i mean he attacks one
pawn
and i think dude has actually defended
quite cleverly i mean you know very
important to remember in in ending that
activity of the rook is the most
important thing and if you're a pawn
down it doesn't always matter if you can
keep your rooks active which duder has
done and is he going to win a pawn back
here i mean maybe not actually as
clearly as i thought i thought it was no
i thought he was going to come behind
that sea pawn but uh
he can't do that after aroni's last move
so still iranian keeping some pressure i
guess
i was going to say you know i might eat
my words or something but i do think
it's not that easy for duda i don't
think he's fully neutralized white's
pressure just yet and by pressure i mean
basically white just has to hold the
position tight defend the pawn that's
under attack and at the right time bring
the king to the defense of the weak pawn
and then he will be able to release a
rook
the problem is anytime your king
centralizes this is a huge weakness on
the h2 square so
first black's rooks are just too active
uh hitting the e2 pawn now and if this
if the white king steps across to defend
yeah black goes on the attack against
this guy
isolated and a weak pawn simply
so i guess white has to step this pawn
forward but suddenly this black rook is
so strong i can envisage for example
okay he does move his king across but i
could envisage the black pawn stepping
forward if we see a trade on this square
suddenly there's a check suddenly
black's rooks are really creating some
menacing threats
so yeah here already the evaluation bar
is slightly in black's favor despite
being a pawn down
so if we go back to the current position
is it because of a move such as the rook
coming across is it because black can
for example bring his rook to this file
um
does he push a pawn just to open up
lines for his rooks
either way it feels like black is doing
decently the problem for white is this
pawn is so far away from pushing even if
you push forward
it's going to be hard to defend this
this pawn long term
white's rook meanwhile is so passive
feels like duda should be okay still as
ivanka mentioned some accuracy required
to win back your pawn or
kind of
simplify things favorably but
he is capable dude and he's got so much
time nearly 10 minutes to find a key
move okay he does bring his rook across
that's slightly surprising just waiting
what is the idea there
i mean his rooks are still so good i
mean this is where his compensation is
duda i mean uh
white's rooks are
not great but yeah you're right that
that move is a little bit mysterious it
doesn't have uh this is a clear idea
does it i can see and just wants to
attack this pawn and win it i guess yeah
maybe keep it as simple as he can
but uh do you think because some of the
lines that david highlighted actually
seem to be very uncomfortable for whites
maybe he's kind of not in the mood to
kind of put pressure on lev and instead
is deciding just to equalize the game i
think he'd love to get a draw here and
just get this game out the way and
ronians probably
you know feeling it's probably a draw
but he's going to keep playing so still
still something there isn't there for
white because you you do have that pawn
um
i mean yeah i'm still trying to find the
right move for irony in here uh it's
it's it's
not easy is that to to see how he can
defend that pawn because if he loses
that pawn they can shake hands
straight away even if levon has those
double pawns that doesn't really matter
yeah not right now i mean if one set of
rooks leave the board um it would be a
factor for example um if white just
makes uh okay okay i guess the move
correctly that's good but for example
okay white's idea is to drop his rook
back and defend this pawn but even if he
just lets it go and we see a trade then
this
set of doubled pawns is not really a
factor because they can easily be
defended both of those two pawns um they
would be a real issue if black for
example had a knight or a bishop around
to jump
and attack or utilize these weak light
squares but that's the problem with
rooks you can't really utilize weak
squares
like you can with minor pieces
so um yeah if that pawn disappears then
structurally this is not an issue for
white in the current position maybe it's
a small issue just because
it's not really about these pawns being
weak because they can be defended but uh
it's more about this guy being isolated
um so it's just about whether to switch
the attack
at that point i was wondering about that
move david i mean that that but that
seems very double edged i mean if the
rook does
as you say swing over i mean the first
thing i'd think of here let's just try
to queen the pawn
and not worry about it and does black
have enough counter play um on the king
side here because that pawn is so strong
when when you've got a pass pawn
as white does here if you've got a rook
behind that past pawn it increases in
value a lot so
so this would be this would become very
sharp when all of a sudden with a lot of
danger especially to um uh duda i mean
he could he has to stop that pawn i
don't see how he can easily do that here
so it's not he has to be a bit careful
right rook takes pawn is just met by
white's king shuffling across gaining
time against the rook rook runs away and
then you motor forward and only three
squares away so um in the current
position definitely it feels like dude
is reluctant to move away the blockade
of this pawn first he goes back
attacking the front weakness the front
double pawn stepping upon forward now to
defend it and duder says okay now you've
weakened your second rank i'm gonna go
back and now this is potentially a
target if you imagine both blacks rooks
landing on the second rank that would be
disastrous for white
but uh anytime he hasn't won that pawn
back don't i mean is
you know you're bankrupt i think
i'm sort of going more your way now that
okay it is a pawn um i think it's still
very hard to win because black's works
are very good blacks very solid and i
don't know if white can make any
progress but it is a porn now it seems
to be a safe safer extra pawn right
um
feels like dude is just playing a bit
too quickly he could
maybe invest just three or four minutes
here or on the last few moves he would
have found a way to win the pawn back or
find a direct path to a draw but yeah
he's he feels like he's drifting very
slightly
um he's very confident here clearly that
duda that he thinks he can just draw
this game but
yeah as you guys say the longer this
pawn survives the more the greater
white's winning chances are
now double pawns they obviously got a
very bad rumor after queen's gambit is
it deserved or can double pawns be
you know if not good
maybe not as bad as the queen's gambit
says there
i think there's different levels of
double pawns as well so there's kind of
doubled isolated pawns so for example
here white has double prawns on the file
but white also has a pawn on the e file
to kind of next to those pawns to
protect them so they're not that weak
they do control a lot of squares those
two white pawns they take away squares
from the black rooks
um we saw yesterday it was uh in a game
from richard rapport where he won very
nicely he had doubled pawns as black but
they covered so many central squares
that actually they were real uh they
were really a strong point in his
position if anything so i think double
points are only weak if they can be
attacked
um or if it comes down to a pawn race
then kind of having two pawns on the
same file is a bit clumsy it doesn't
really help in a race but
i don't know there's some dynamic
compensation for them definitely because
there's an open line isn't there so um i
always judge them by how well they can
move if they can't move forward so
easily
and there are a lot of pieces
controlling the squares in front then
maybe they're a little bit of a
liability but then again you've got to
die uh balance that out with all the
dynamic possibilities that you get
because of this open line and uh
here as david uh mentioned earlier you
know the rooks just can't make use of
those weak squares that's around the
pawns so here they're just absolutely
fine they're protected
they can't be won easily
and
they're i don't think they're neither
good or they're neither bad normally
when you get double pawns you often get
something else in return anyway so here
by getting the double pawns ironian
actually won a pawn in the process so
he's one point up he would rather be a
porn up
with double pawns than level material
without double pawns if that makes sense
and often in order to double your pawns
your opponent has to for example trade
off a bishop for a night so you get the
bishop pair or you get something like
you've access you get an open file in
return and there are often kind of
extenuating
circumstances so it's you just don't
want double pawns in a position where
they can be attacked easily blockaded
i was just looking at his position i was
just thinking if black doesn't do
anything um how can white win i've just
come up with one plan but i really can't
see like any way this is a good way to
look at positions you know but how can
you improve your position right if your
opponent doesn't do anything and in some
rare cases it's best not to do anything
you know literally just to sit there and
say to your opponent come on i'm just
gonna like read a book here or saying
chill out you've got to do something and
the only thing i can think of is maybe
the rook on d4
can come to c3 and come to c2 or
something is that is that a possible
idea to improve the position because you
want to sort of
improve the position slowly right and
these kind of things and i think i'd
love to swap a pair of rooks i was
probably still a draw
even if i do that but
you know any way to improve and uh maybe
i appreciate pawn two squares first to
you know just to improve my position
over there um because i you know that's
always a good move isn't it um but in
general maybe is that a plan david maybe
is to do something like that you called
it simon harry the h1 marches forward um
but also notice how strong the two
double pawns are that uh actually duda
spent a move trying to
prepare a plan to exchange off the
double pawns and kind of rectify white
structure
especially this white pawn really strong
but uh yeah to answer your point simon
so for example black just waits does
nothing um you mentioned bring the rook
back black weights bring the rook across
black weights and then offering a rook
exchange
it makes some sense because a rook trade
i want to try i want to try to give
myself the opportunity is white to bring
my king towards the past pawn which i
couldn't do before because black's work
was so strong on the position so i
swapped off my opponent's strongest
piece and that that's what i'm aiming
for but even here
the double pawns well you're leaving
harry weak aren't you this is always a
problem as you pointed out so black if
the king comes over black will be able
to pick up that loose pawn minimum and
uh even this i mean this doesn't seem
you know that worrying for black and
black maybe it's just waiting now yeah
so
that's really interesting a plan like
that one
um i think another idea that i'd be
tempted by with white uh sorry in the
game position
is to activate this rook at some point
for example swing it across try to creep
in through the seventh rank
so for example if black gets greedy and
goes for the white extra pawn then we
can give a check
wherever the black king goes
then we can suddenly
dive in and you conquer the seventh rank
this is a checkmate threat actually if
you win this pawn
so uh this would be very very nice for
white i'm just wondering how duda would
meet a move like that one uh trying to
bring the rook across maybe he'd just
retreat his own rook yeah that was uh
also my thinking as well david uh
just to retreat the rook and hold tight
i wonder if you can push the pawn there
i mean i i
i don't know it seems very risky oh you
just come behind right yeah it doesn't
work somehow like white needs two moves
in the go and then
then it'll be okay but uh for the time
being i mean
at the minute this is just uh what is a
grind you know objectively the position
is probably a draw
but
you know they have to play it they have
to find those accurate moves and this is
what makes end game so exciting is this
one of those typical magnus carlsen
positions where he would this as well
yes this would make it into david's
course yeah yeah if white wins this one
it is it's the david course position is
there a hundred percent iranian can
grind this one down yeah meanwhile a
really odd move guys the king has come
forward so uh what happens if white oh
he just moves his king i was gonna say
what happens if white tries this plan
now going to the seventh rank going for
this pawn because black can say yes i'm
going to win this pawn but suddenly we
go across we come up and we win this guy
a bit of a strange one is that a small
missed opportunity perhaps i'm really
surprised the black king abandoned the
seventh rank
uh there yeah i'm surprised as well um
especially because he seems to and he's
left the king again on the f6 square and
it really is just asking white look at
the evaluation bar maybe the white rook
can just come to the seventh franc this
is actually the big target in the black
position
and okay again aronian he's in grind
mode he doesn't want to do anything kind
of concrete he doesn't want to
kind of seize the moment yet he just
wants to improve his pieces he's not
sure how this improves the pieces to be
honest but the problem is the chance is
gone black's king steps back and white's
rook can no longer enter on the seventh
rank
yeah
he's making useful moves but maybe not
the most incisive uh incisive moves i
mean he's got to do something hasn't it
at some point as well i mean he he's got
to find some kind of plan and i do like
your idea of activating the rook even if
you lose lose your past pawn
trying to transfer one advantage to the
other
uh okay he's gone back so he's not maybe
your plan is in the air over doubling
the risks and offering a trade i suppose
the big threat here is to come to b1 and
come around that way like like we've
just seen
um
okay so this is a good move and
yeah we got this position i
mentioned but it's still actually very
hard for white to progress here isn't it
yeah he has to bring in the king doesn't
he and uh okay
dude are taking
a cautionary step backwards and very
defensive but i think it's necessary
and it's up to lavon to now find a plan
to improve the position
and
whilst the players are thinking
it's
to have time to share with you a few
selfies
okay he pushes his pawn forward jessica
says
that she is
okay and the rooks have now lined up
she's watching some semi-final action
with her fuzzy friends
that's very nice
and uh
evie and growl life and
oh there's a couple of pokemon
what's the middle one oh we have a
secret pokemon
i didn't even know
okay
sorry uh yeah let us know jessica what's
the middle one my eyesight's not good
enough okay well uh jessica yes let us
know and abhishek tells us you know
what's tougher than beating a grand
master in chess it's managing to eat
your ice cream cone completely without
it being snatched by a seagull on
brighton here now the funny story about
that is actually i was walking with
david in clandudno and we were eating
ice cream i went from nowhere the sea
girl came and stole his ice cream
i have a well it's not a love-hate
relationship it's just a hate
relationship with seagulls
oh my god every time i have an ice cream
if the weather's even slightly warm a
seagull will poach it really as ivanka
said we just bought some really
expensive ice cream one minute outside
the shop seagull comes in i recently
queued up for 20 minutes at mcdonald's
to get a mcflurry one step out of the
shop seagull swooped in
[Laughter]
flurries are not cheap in norway
you know i'll join your we hate seagulls
group on facebook david i mean they are
just pooping all over my miranda i have
to clean it every day i hate them
david's got baby pigeons i think oh yeah
i had a pigeon problem during the
candidates tournament i was commentating
i had to go and take a break to try and
get rid uh they'd laid an egg in my
gutter no yeah we it was a bit sad we
had to move the egg and the sea and the
pigeons were a bit upset but
yeah these birds in the summer they
think they can get away with anything
but uh also abhishek in that tweet
brighton that's pretty much my hometown
yeah
i lived there for five years as well so
yeah down west part of the world is that
like a nice summer uh city in england
it's a good place to have fun yeah i
reckon it's better than london i'm gonna
say it oh yeah i reckon it's a better
place everyone goes to london too busy
too hectic brighton's got loads of
little lanes great pubs it's really cool
yeah brighton's a great place to go so
yeah
today do you agree london or brighton oh
brighton every title yeah come on
actually brighton football team seagulls
and uh meanwhile let's go back to the
game because uh well duda has uh played
this porn move
i mean is this just
completely neutralizing levon's attack
or is it just one step too far in the
defensive yeah he's
i mean it feels like he's going through
an identity crisis in a way dude he at
first he wants to go active then he
wants to go passive and just sit there
and do nothing now he's going active
again by swapping off uh all these pawns
and
okay level neronian he's got so much
time on the clock but he made a
committal decision he had so many
options on the last go we see more pawns
leave the board which is actually good
for duda but uh if we just jump in a few
moves ago
just when duda pushed this pawn forward
levon had options for example he could
lock down the position he could push
this pawn he could actually
just keep another set of pawns on the
board he could move his king forward
potentially saying yes you can grab here
but then the white king comes across
then i'm going to start grabbing your
pawns
i don't know to me this looks good but
yeah so many options i'm not sure which
is the best but he just very quickly
took these pawns and very quickly moved
forward i mean if we compare the
position david you know that first move
i mean just pushing the pawn uh one
square forwards like h5 if we go back
yep um and then we could get the same
thing as in the game but um maybe then
that pawns can be weak but i think
generally you want to keep pawns on the
board right generally if you want to win
you've got to keep more pawns on the
board the way the game's going i mean
there's so there's not many pawns you
can clean i mean it's really simplified
even though you're a porn up um
i mean obviously it's it's a draw
technically but a bit careful but still
you're right i mean we skip ahead now
back to the current position and yeah i
mean i just don't see how white is ever
going to win this one
i mean this pawn and this pawn basically
balance each other out
and your only hope is this guy oh
sorry me and my arrows the only hope is
this guy but uh yeah firstly stepping it
forward isn't going to be easy anytime
soon but uh secondly yeah you're gonna
have to face a whole bunch of checks you
don't have that much shelter for the
white king this is a check you have to
block um you don't want to move because
this would be nasty um so okay we did
see a block and after a rook trade
slightly surprising there but uh dude
over in lavon try to push that pawn
usually i would think so but i guess
because there's so few pawns left
um judah should be okay he's going to
try and use his king to blockade this
pawn potentially and then his rook will
be the active piece you definitely want
it that way round you want your king
passive rook active
and uh yeah i think blackstroke is gonna
do a good job if there were more pawns
on the board for example if you imagine
black had uh two pawns here white had
two more pawns here i think white would
have great winning chances just because
this pawn would be a distraction and
then later white could try and create a
second pass pawn but yeah just
everything's disappearing unfortunately
and okay now
all duda needs to do is find a way after
he moves his rook for example across he
needs to find a way to trade off these
guys leave white with just one pawn
that's easy uh easy to blockade and it
will be a draw
so okay he attacks this pawn instead
white will defend it with his king
and now dude's idea is to block
everything with the black king
okay so you fully expect this to end in
a draw in what kind of way more
repetition or something like that yeah
maybe just everything being traded off
actually dude brings this rook across
yeah i think there's just no progress to
be made for white at the moment your
rook is stuck defending this pawn if you
ever bring your king across the problem
is the rook switches back to attack this
one you bring your king back across the
rook switches back to attack this one
the black rook is basically going to
oscillate between the current square and
the square it's just going to go back
and forth
and white can do nothing i think we'll
see a result any moment
well the vulneran with the white pieces
i guess it's uh duda who will be the
most happy about that result after every
game they will have 15-minute break and
game two will start it is best out of
four rapid games in the semi-final
matches and if they are tied then they
will play blitz
and potentially armageddon tie breaks
i don't know what it is with the cameras
but it looks like phantom of the opera
or something in uh dudes oh it's very
dramatic it looks like he's wearing half
a mask or something
i'm just waiting for his uh is he
wearing a hoodie i said no it's a
t-shirt obviously yeah
and here we go and this should be a
drawstring
yeah like hopefully now i mean i think
it's like quite a high standard game
and um
levon shaking his head yeah i mean i
don't think
he'd never really had any winning
chances i mean he was always a little
bit better but so what you know and you
get this kind of game a lot of this and
now more paws exchange they can shake
hands they probably do but
um
i mean this is why sometimes like the
high level games i i find them a bit
more boring than when there's more
errors you know i know this is a bit
controversial but when you see very
tactical games where people the bars
going left and right is swinging all
over shop i find them a bit more a bit
more dramatic than these better played
better quality games uh in general um
you're not a true grind assignment i'm
certainly not a grinder i'm not as you
know i'm a crash band wadapper
okay no grinding for me
like crash bang wallop i think it's
probably an english phrase is it an
english phrase there's even a song crash
bang what a picture
what a photograph i've never never heard
that right now so why do you want a joke
thrown off in a couch with smokers
is it a song yeah oh okay i don't know
where i got it from i think i think well
i went to a southeast london primary
school and it was also random education
we didn't do any maths we didn't do any
grammar we didn't learn anything but we
we seem to have learned songs from the
and
we have a result right because
levon has left his chair and the
position is just